>> Laura: BEST WEEK EVER.
THAT’S THE FOCUS OF TONIGHT’S
ANGLE.
IT’S NOT EVEN CLOSE.
THIS WAS THE BEST WEEK OF
DONALD TRUMP’S PRESIDENCY ON
EVERY FRONT.
HE IS WINNING ON THE ECONOMY,
NATIONAL SECURITY, ADDITIONAL
APPOINTMENTS, EVEN
LEGISLATIVELY.
HIS POLICIES AND STRATEGIES ARE
WORKING IN THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
ARE REAPING HUGE BENEFITS.
>> IF YOU’RE AN AMERICAN LOOKING
FOR WORK, IT’S A GOOD ECONOMY.
>> HISTORIC LOW UNEMPLOYMENT
NUMBERS.
>> TRUMP ECONOMY DOING PRETTY
WELL.
>> Laura: HE HAS THE BEST
CABINET I CAN RECALL ANY
PRESIDENT HAVING IN MY LIFETIME.
AS WE DISCUSSED, THE WHITE HOUSE
IS FINALLY DOING SOME MUCH
NEEDED HOUSECLEANING.
KEEP IT UP.
GET RID OF THE RADICALS
UNDERMINING FROM WITHIN AND
REPLACE THEM WITH PEOPLE WHO
BELIEVE IN YOUR AGENDA,
MR. PRESIDENT, WHO ARE CONFIDENT
ENOUGH TO IT OUT.
FOR THREE YEARS, THE LIBERAL
INTELLIGENTSIA PREDICTED DOOM
FOR TRUMP’S PRESIDENCY AND IT
RETURNED.
>> THERE IS AN ACKNOWLEDGMENT
INSIDE THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN THAT
THEY DON’T KNOW HOW THEIR
CANDIDATE CAN SURVIVE THIS AT
THIS POINT.
>> HE’S GOT DONALD McGAHN
TALKING THAT MANY HOURS.
ONE ANECDOTE HE TELLS GOOD CAUSE
ON DONALD TRUMP A LOT OF
PROBLEMS.
>> ARE WE WITNESSING THE END OF
THE TRUMP PRESIDENCY?
>> Laura: [LAUGHS]
I LOVE THOSE CLIPS.
WRONG!
WHEN TRUMP DELIVERED THE STATE
OF THE UNION ON TUESDAY, HE DID
SO WITH THE HIGHEST APPROVAL
RATING OF HIS TENURE, 49%,
HIGHER THAN OBAMA’S APPROVAL AT
THE SAME TIME IN 2012.
HE EASILY -- REMEMBER OBAMA
CRUISED TO REELECTION LATER THAT
YEAR.
THESE WERE THE SAME GENIUSES WHO
WERE PREDICTING CRACKED G.O.P.
UNITY HEADING INTO IMPEACHMENT.
>> WHO WOULD VOTE FOR A
CONVICTION OF REPUBLICANS?
>> I WOULD GIVE THE HIGH END
PROBABLY FIVE TO TEN.
I THINK THAT’S REALISTIC.
>> THERE IS THE CHANCE THERE
WILL BE 20 REPUBLICANS.
I’M NOT PREDICTING IT.
I WOULDN’T BET ON IT BUT I THINK
THERE’S A CHANCE.
>> I THINK ROMNEY HAS HELPED MAY
BE REASSURES SPEAKER PELOSI
THERE’S A POSSIBILITY OF
REPUBLICAN SUPPORT, MAY BE IN
THE SENATE.
>> Laura: IF BILL KRISTOL
PREDICTS IT, BET THE OTHER SIDE.
ROMNEY WAS THE SOLE PEER DEFECTO
DEFECTO.
NOT ONLY DID REPUBLICANS STICK
TOGETHER, THEY HAD A REASON TO
CELEBRATE IT LIKE IT WAS 2016
ALL OVER AGAIN.
WE DIDN’T PLAY ALL OF IT.
IT WAS CRAZY.
I WAS IN THE ROOM.
THE LEFT HASN’T BEEN RIGHT SINCE
ABOUT 2012 IF YOU THINK ABOUT IT
AND SINCE THEN, IT’S BEEN ONE
BUST OF A PREDICTION AFTER
ANOTHER.
>> THE U.S. ECONOMY GROWING AT
AN UNSUSTAINABLE RATE.
>> WAGES ADJUSTED FOR INFLATION
ARE ACTUALLY WORSE UNDER
DONALD TRUMP AND THEY WERE UNDER
BARACK OBAMA.
>> I KEEP HEARING FROM PEOPLE
SAYING THEY ARE STILL
STRUGGLING.
>> Laura: NOT QUITE, KIDS.
>> FRESH ECONOMIC NUMBERS SHOW A
BOOMING, RESILIENT LABOR MARKET.
>> THE ECONOMY ADDED 225,000
JOBS.
>> 3.1% WAGE GROWTH.
>> I HAVE TO SAY THE
MIDDLE-CLASS BOOM, THE
BLUE-COLLAR BOOM CONTINUES.
>> Laura: THESE ARE THE GOOD
OLD DAYS, FOLKS.
SURVEYS ARE SHOWING AMERICANS
ARE HAPPIER THAN THEY HAVE BEEN
FOR FOUR DECADES, EVEN HAPPIER
THAN UNDER RONALD REAGAN.
THIS IS GREAT NEWS FOR AMERICA
WHICH MEANS IT’S TERRIBLE NEWS
FOR THE DEMOCRATS.
I THINK CONGRESSWOMAN DEBBIE
DINGELL MIGHT HAVE SUMMED IT UP
BEST.
>> EVERYBODY WANTS TO GET OUT OF
TOWN TODAY.
I THINK THIS HAS BEEN QUITE
FRANKLY IN MY CAREER NOT JUST
HERE BUT IN MY PROFESSIONAL
CAREER ONE OF THE WORST WEEKS
THAT I CAN REMEMBER.
>> Laura: [LAUGHS]
NOW WE ALL KNOW WHY THE LADIES
WERE WEARING WHITE DURING THE